[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
il
[Musique]
allô allô
ah mais c'est trop tard voici c'est un
portail rappellera ouais ça fait de la
pub on les déteste
alalalala quel dommage triple dommage
pour cet auditeur qui n'a pas décroché
car aujourd'hui je vous le rappelle nous
multiplions par seize votre salaire
pendant 32 ans en attendant nous passons
une belle après-midi tueur bonne chance
est fait
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
abonnez-vous et si vous préférez quand
on se fait très mal cliquez ici tiens
c'est carlito halo ouest ont pris alors
retrouvé le faso c'est une superbe
émission sur une chaîne
on a compris une raccroche je raccroche
mai